in the previous video we started working
on a ruin we took off the roof and had a
better look at the structure itself
it's rough and basic patch together
brickwork with some additional things
stuffed in there with cement
it misses some essential structural
strength on the bottom and the top ball
is very weak taking down is probably
cheaper and easier but we like to try
and keep as much as possible the
materials in their existing state
so first step is reinforcing so we have
a strong base
so yeah welcome to a new project camp
update let's get started
so this is the bottom of the ruin built
of granite which makes it very strong
and the floor is leaning on top except
this part right here this is made from
bricks
which is not structurally strong enough
to hold the entire floor so we need to
reinforce this part we're going to
probably make a metal frame to make sure
not all the load is on the bricks but
it's actually on a strong frame and the
frame will be coming here on the granite
so the first thing we're going to do is
clean up this edge so we can measure it
and make a proper frame
and the floor down here in this room is
also not leveled at all
they're super low in that corner here
it's very high
so as we're working with the hammer to
clean up the hydro plug we're also just
going to clean up this one
and after that level it to make sure we
have a good base
so time to hammer
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so the stony work is now done
this edge here is leveled and straight
so now we're going to make a metal frame
that supports the roof
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
after we cut the frame into its size
it's time to weld it together we're
using a 12 centimeter h beam to carry
the load it's the thickest heaviest
object we made here so far from metal
so taking it down is a bit of a
challenge let's see how that goes
[Music]
[Music]
wait
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'll be the guy down here
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
after we managed to carry it down we
gave it a paint job ready to go in
and moving here was already challenging
but what's actually way bigger challenge
is cutting it up that edge
mainly because it's just heavy but what
made it more challenging is that we can
just easily put it on there
since it's quite a tight space and gap
between the edge and the ceiling it's
like a centimeter
but the whole ceiling and walls are
wobbly and curved so we ask a few hands
to help out and try to bring the thing
into its position
it worked fine in terms of lifting but
unfortunately it didn't fit
still some wobbly wall so yeah we needed
to bring it down again cut it once more
and then try it again
[Music]
what will be the next steps
[Music]
bring it
up and finally with the help of all
hands on project camp we made it
we managed to lift it again and fit it
perfectly
so now we can continue with the
renovation after the bottom was
reinforced it was time to have a look at
this beautiful brick wall on top
[Music]
hey
so today we're gonna have a look at this
very beautiful wall it's a very sketchy
while not stable at all
and we want to
chop out a piece here
the main reason is because the wall is
already very terrible here so we have to
rebuild it anyway
and we're going to make space to insert
a sliding door
mom so this would also become the main
entrance of the building
and we're a bit scared of that wall
because it's very unstable at this point
so tim made a very good safety
measurement it's this sketchy wall
connected to this sketchy wall
which make sure they don't fall over
[Music]
don't tighten it too much you'll pull
the ball in
put a little bit of
hardly any tension in it and yet the
whole wall is shaking
so the first thing we're going to do is
you cut a line and then break by brick
we're going to take it down ideally we
save as much as possible so we can
rebuild some holes
tim is getting ready there in the shade
i think it's safe tim
i think it's as safe as we could make it
you hold it a bit
yeah
[Music]
all right so the wall is now out
went surprisingly easy i think we almost
saved all the bricks
because they were not really stuck
um and now we're gonna at the end of the
day we're gonna
cement it a bit back the holes in the
frame put the lentil here on top
but now it's going to be too warm so
we're going to
take a little siesta and then continue
see you later
straight line
not straight
[Music]
special announcement
all right so we are looking for a new
video maker
yes at the beginning of the season we
had felix helping us out to make videos
for season two
but unfortunately he has to stop a few
reasons it's because it's just heavy on
the setting
to edit videos with flies and it's hot
not a stable office
but also really producing a video each
week is quite intense he's not used to
that
and in general i think also just youtube
comments a lot of opinions can make it
hard so unfortunately he won't be able
to continue so we're looking for a new
video maker we're actually aiming to get
two to also just reduce a bit the
workload on the video maker itself
um so this is a request to you guys if
you're interested in making videos here
come and help out or maybe your friends
that want to come
and we wrote an article or post or i
don't know community post on the youtube
with more information also about the
reasons why felix stopped also what
we're looking for
in short making videos until the end of
the season which would be november
and then until update number 70. so you
can do the map until when that is
and it will be producing a weekly video
so if you're interested make sure to
read that post with all the information
and sign up to help out
uh yeah now back to the rune
[Applause]
[Music]
try
so it's now end of the day we're in the
shade so we started cleaning the bricks
to get the old cement off they're now
here and tim is putting them back
together and
so the frame sticks in there
so we built this up put the lentil on
top and then should be good
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
next we're gonna add the windows we will
add some in the bottom so it's not a
dark cave and in the top to fill well
the window holes that are already there
and we got in touch with ronald he had a
bunch of glass and window frames left
over from his home renovation a few
years ago he gave it to us for our
future buildings
for the rune we are going to use the
double glass and he has a few cool
wooden frames with that
so here we have some windows we have
this one
which is a window double glass which is
cool with a frame but not the external
frame so we would need to make that
big door
there's also a whole stack of just
double glass
i think he ordered it but it was wrong
or something for his house so it's
pretty new but doesn't have any framing
around it so we need to find a way to
add those
but i think we're going to use this one
and this one for the bruin
so our wu tools are not very advanced
yet so we brought it to a local wood guy
so we could make a frame around it
and he made the frames pretty basic not
angled
and no water drainage in there we would
think the water would flow just inside
but his suggestion was to put the frames
under a small angle so the entire frame
and the water then just flows out which
is apparently a very common to do around
here a bit skeptical about this approach
but hey it's a sketchy rune so let's see
so here we have windows that are already
there and our windows that we just made
are
somewhat fitting the height fits in but
they need to have a few centimeters here
chopped out so we're probably going to
chop a few on the left and the right so
that we can keep the lentil above
and then the windows should fit in
[Music]
so
[Music]
so before we were working a lot with the
stairs just because that was the only
thing we had
but now we ask george a neighbor if you
had some scaffolding
so he borrowed us some very classic
traditional portuguese scaffolding
a bit rusty bit heavy
but this is the thing they use around
here
so yeah we're gonna put it up and from
then on we should be
able to work better at a height
especially if we start doing the windows
upstairs and the roof
and let's puzzle this together
save the switches
stairs
stackable
cross that goes in the back
and the wooden shelf
[Music]
and
[Music]
very safe
[Music]
so next we're going to do the two
windows here on top they're gonna be
slightly different because we're first
gonna put in a granite frame and then
the wooden one
it's a bit more of a proper way of doing
it it's also very common actually to do
around here because you find a lot of
granite and many of the houses here have
that frame
so we got some granite we got the wooden
frames some cement now we're just gonna
build them in here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right so let me show you the final
result
so we now have a window that can open
which creates a good airflow with the
door
another window here that gives a good
view to the outside
reinforced frame to make sure the whole
thing doesn't collapse
then on the outside we have the big hole
for the door big sliding door it's not
installed yet because you first want to
do a bit more work on the inside
and you might think how do you get into
that door
so the plan is to build a bit of a
balcony here in front that you can sit
outside and this would also be the main
entrance
main reason also for doing that is that
this door is just really low
so we're going to close this one up and
then we can also
arrange the interior a bit easier
over here we have a window frame from
the granite finished ready to put in the
wood
it's under a slight angle to make sure
the water and the rain
flows out and not in
here we already put in a frame just so
you can see what it looks like
yeah very convenient if i look outside i
look straight at the granite and to
really see the view i just do a bit of
bending
and next we also actually wanted to take
out this wall
because you have an awesome view back
here
but we're a bit scared of taking out
this one at this point
because
it gives strength to that wall which is
still very fragile
so the next step would actually be
to build a wooden frame
that makes everything structurally
strong connected together we're also
going to look into the insulation what
to do with that
if you already want to see the next
video
make sure to subscribe on patreon so you
can see it or not and just continue to
watch here see you next monday with a
new video
that was it for this one thanks for
watching and
see you next time
and look at the view
[Music]
you